I think the decision to come here to
America it's like now I will gain myself
and I will have myself in my hand and I
will I will try to shape my my life as
the way it is the way I see it as Mona
see it era yeah thank you so what can I
help you with today I came here for a
job excuse me a job I would like a job
I'm sorry I thought you wanted to open
an account
I came from Palestine you know her
the last time is it Jewish speaking
country no Arabic I went out of oh don't
blow the place up
I'm just kidding actually we're not
really hiring at this time I have a long
experience you can see from my resume a
here please
great we'll certainly keep this on file
and also I came here because my sister
she had account with you I promise if
you give me a job I will open my account
also here we'll keep that in mind
I have so many different things but I
like the way she she didn't just let it
down no she said I will try it more and
more and more and hard even it was so
hard for her to see her son arrested or
she said no this is the time that we
should really decide what we want to do
or to stay here and to survive here in
America okay or to go back there